what is a good diet for strength
development
i've uh just to give you some context
i've been eating mostly meat
not for strength mostly for mental
performance i just enjoy it
yes you need to have a base level of
protein building blocks for tissue right
we need to have enough fats to be able
to have
hormones work and key processes in the
body we need to have
well you don't need to have from a
performance aspect carbohydrates
necessarily because the other ones can
convert into injury sources but for a
performance athlete carbohydrates can be
very beneficial
as well so
so i look at it as
you want you need a base level fats you
need a base level of proteins and then
you adjust the carbohydrate intake based
on the needs i'm not anti-carbohydrate
by any means
because a lot of people will they look
at me now when they see like how lean i
am and they they jump to a conclusion
you must be keto you must be carnivore
you must be whatever and it's like
so losing and gaining weight is simply
eating less or eating more
i mean it
ah
and we get so complicated oh that my fat
they're like what's your fasting window
if i'm
if i'm doing fasting it's just because
it works with my
my environment sometimes i do it
sometimes i don't
all that does is control how much
calories that you take big success with
keto and carnivore diets it's hard to
eat a lot
uh and and put on weight with those with
those diets um
you know protein actually has a
thermogenic effect and so you have to
have a massive amount of fats if you
have a only meat diet because you can
literally starve to death there's a
there's a show where they put people out
in the wilderness and this guy the one
that won one of the ones i looked and
they threw them away like up in the uh
past a lot you know out the way out
there there was nothing but he somehow
got a caribou and killed it and he still
lost a pound a day for 30 days with a
caribou
because his fat was stolen by a uh
uh and and he could eat all the meat he
wanted yeah and then he almost got
pulled because his weight loss right
but that isn't actually a performance so
those type of keto and carnivore are not
performance diets so
they're not going to
be as effective at supplying
the energy needs for high capacity
training so don't get me wrong you can
do training but like
you can be a successful like elite
athlete with a with a vegan diet but
it's not as easy to do it with other
diets so and you're missing some base
nutrients so many nutrients in meat i
believe uh having greens in your diet is
really beneficial lots of research but
there's people in the other worlds that
argue that they don't need them but they
help clear organs provide micronutrients
all this sort of stuff so
i eat simply a whole well-rounded diet
and i've gone from
i can go from 285 pounds squatting a ton
of weight to eating less and dropping
all the way down to you know seven eight
percent body fat with veins standing out
everywhere without a
tissue on me just
with amazing great tasting food
to lose weight or be healthy does not
mean that you need to eat flavorless
bland
food so that's the main thing
portions
it's eat less to lose weight eat more to
gain weight yep make sure that you've
got enough protein make sure that you've
got your micronutrients covered which is
going to cover by eating real food don't
go low fat no fat if you want a
performance don't go no carb but if it
works any of those things
so diet approach when you look at diets
understand
that they're how aggressive they are so
like keto can make you lose a lot of
weight carnivore can make you lose a lot
of weight a lot of that up front is
actually glo dropping glycogen stores
so you're actually just reducing water
in your muscle and fat tissue um so
which is why it doesn't isn't as great
for a performance diet but understand
that every diet
also has a level of discipline and does
it fit your lifestyle
so i suggest people don't find a diet
you need to find a lifestyle because
that's what's sustainable i hate the
word diet to begin with
what behaviors
are sustainable
and then do that and then over time the
things you'll get to where you need to
get
diet
itself just by the name of it is not
sustainable because it it is a
short-term thing to get somewhere
yeah i tend to try to measure it because
i definitely have a love-hate
relationship with food
i tend to look back and say like
by following this particular protocol
lifestyle whatever
uh what was the level of happiness
yes so not like
weight loss or weight gain or all those
kinds of things it's the entirety of the
picture productivity just feeling good
throughout the day socially also like
yeah interacting with people because so
much of uh human connection like i
mentioned before is over food
and if you're going to limit yourself in
that regard you're limiting a certain
fundamental aspect of life
a number of years ago
um i did uh like 20 to 22-hour fasts
every day and i'm like well this doesn't
work i'm i can't do business lunches and
stuff like that so when i was in my
fasting thing i went to a 16 so i could
have a light lunch just for the social
aspect of it and perform a little
perform that like
um
and then that's why and that's why like
the typical bodybuilding like the eight
meal a day diet um has never worked for
me because i've always been a very bit
like trying to fit that between meetings
and other stuff
what that diet provides is it just you
get less bloat and distension of a
larger meal
but at the end of the day you get the
same exact results pick a lifestyle live
that you can have really great tasting
food
and that to me is the same thing and
this is why i'm like really hitting this
point because
also with the dieting and like the
approach like oh i'm gonna do this and
people pick
these chicken and broccoli recipes and
guess what you're going to break if you
do not in if you do not enjoy it
you will break
so
that's it is a very important point well
i also
slightly push back or maybe to elaborate
if you don't enjoy
moderation
for me particularly
i have trouble moderating certain things
most foods i would say so my source of
happiness comes with foods even if
they're bland
the ones that can enjoy but enjoy
moderation
so there's i mean i enjoy every piece of
food so it's like it's uh if you can
enjoy the
the full lifestyle it's not just the
particular experience but like the full
journey yep does it fit your lifestyle
yeah
you